welcome to this video playing mmv bar
with that their name nope okay and the
Queens gambit there's one day after all
those years here how many Coons gambits
staff had on the board here a couple of
ten thousands probably and maybe more
this must be a lot okay and so he just
replaced with with e6 slide bd7 going in
to earn yeah classical type of Queens
gambit makuu not be three is not ideally
placed but this is this is what what it
is i mean at least i have them yeah
brought him to this kind of setup which
is not the most ambitious as well so
what is he doing them if he takes i just
want to take in one move from f1 nope
okay if he takes i wonder if i can take
with the Queen oh I said insane be five
Quincy 6ad looks a bit insane he takes
Queen takes be 5s while I'm talking
about b5 takes it hmm maybe it's
possible i have bishop g34 Queen c7 for
me maybe it's possible as one of those
famous last words and maybe that kitchen
pull did that thing in the kitchen isn't
that how that isn't that what ok I can
actually move I cannot do that I cannot
move the night well my idea was Bishop
d3 anyway but it's not going to work but
should be seven Quincy seven takes takes
Bishop f three years is on so it's that
way I can go to a eight actually if he
if he pays rook c7 I can go to EF go to
a eight I need some something against
Roxy seven can I do this should I can go
back and that was kind of shaky to take
that take at pod okay so I'm taking now
here check Knight takes and then crenate
i'm usually not not doing this kind of
porn grabs and I know why it's not good
for your for your whole nervous system
your nerve system this kind of this kind
of things
okay so he's attacking my pawn them and
queen 85 oops both looks dangerous so
maybe before it's probably out for Queen
to be six I guess but i can take f6 i
wonder if i should do that anyhow anyway
taking it before so that I have yeah
let's do that so that I have 24 I don't
think we need five would work here so
let's do before
should be seven is not a threat this may
mean it's checking and go hook see one
what did i do here next time I just play
a good solid Queens gambit not snatch
any pawns yeah yeah yeah do you think
that this was the worst that could have
happened it's not great but I think he
had something better you know but of
course I i have spent ages two to get
them queen bee to that's okay true it's
not working I cannot double them
unfortunately time morning
50 seconds amazing
now the next time I take don't take
those pawns that I know just playing a
normal position and try to grab the
other guy down like every game wow what
a bad idea what a bad idea
well yes I don't really have any play
but i'm still trying to retain them a
little bit d5 takes a 5 some some vague
very vague chances
my rope the eight wins pretty
convincingly I cannot cover d6 a queen
age six might still be a little bit
interesting 95 now is kind of
interesting he really made it
interesting I just have 19 seconds
though Wow check
rook takes this made let's go here now
for queen age five
range i couldn't have just one it
clearly right you needed to do something
and to give me some hope there and i
have no time whatsoever unfortunately
check and I'm blundering it away again
ah great stuff white resins probably
probably I might have a drawing at least
I have it wrong here 23 from that
position unbelievable here I've actually
winning with bishop is six this cannot
defend this wow what a terrible game
check okay at eight seconds so much um
yeah so I shouldn't take that pawn
that's the story of the whole thing the
engine believes I can do it but not for
a human player your queen 85 was already
better trying I don't know sometimes you
just feel tempted him I absolutely hate
to play like that in tournament chess I
would never do it here no it's just not
good young yes that we can you should've
no it's just a bad position i have spent
ages to get to and extract the Queen
yeah t of course I'm just totally lost
but he played it yeah in a way to give
me huge chance at sang the air route g6
what's also interesting they are winning
here now anyway no matter what Jack what
happens to specially six and it's over
Jim it's not so difficult okay add 10
seconds I was the issue okay next time
don't take those pawns okay thanks for
watching